there's not a lot to like about
cockroaches but someday they could save
lives okay well not them exactly but
robots inspired by calculations
cockroaches are such a pain in part
because they can crawl indoor hands
through the smallest of openings but
what if that compression was a good
thing
what if swarms of robotic bugs could be
sent into disaster areas like earthquake
rubble to search for buried people
that's the idea behind this roboroach
that's designed to mimic the cockroaches
in limbo act
it's called crammed compressible robot
with articulated mechanisms researchers
at UC Berkeley press the real cockroach
toward secrets okay sorry about that
and then they designed this robotic
version to do the same
not only can its carapace that's a fancy
word for she'll be crushed but so can
it's motorized body thanks to a hinge
spine in these clever legs that just
keep on trucking no matter how tight the
squeeze this version is still pretty big
but in the future there could be swarms
of miniature Robo roaches equipped with
cameras GPS and other sensors to
wriggles through rubble to fling
survivors imagine just how happy you
might be to see a pile of cockroaches
then